although HBO has been pretty
tight-lipped about Wes Wells upcoming
third season they've still released a
couple of tidbits to keep fans tidied
over until the show returns to screens
here's a roundup of everything we know
about Westworld season 3 well the first
two seasons of Westworld have been
mostly told from the points of view of
Dolores and the man in black if the
first teaser is any indication season 3
seems to be taking a sharp turn into
something new this intriguing glimpse of
Wes Wells new season follows a brand new
character played by Breaking Bad's Aaron
Paul through a series of events that
take place in what appears to be the
real world outside of the Lassa spark
from Paul's narration it sounds as
though the welding habits as a much of
an improvement on the park as he talks
about his sense that's although things
may look nice on the surface that beauty
is masking something darker sound like
something you've heard before some
people choose to see the ugliness in
this world I choose to see the beauty
Paul's character laments that somebody
has made an attempt to smooth over the
world's rough edges making it or little
more than a lie and expresses his hope
of finding something real at which point
the trailer finally shows us a familiar
face of course as you probably know from
previous seasons the men who fall in
with Dolores are rarely or that they
seem nor do they ever get what they
expect
although HBO was yet to announce a
premiere date for season 3 don't hold
your breath on seeing Westworld return
to TV screens and 2019 HBO programming
chief Casey blowies told The Wrap in
early 2019 that production on the series
third season was set to begin in March
of the same year while it's possible
that show runners Jonathan Nolan and
Lisa joy will race to turn the season
around before the end of the year a
20/20 premiere date seems more likely
this would be a slightly longer gap than
the one between the first two seasons
which lasted nearly 17 months season 1
wrapped up in early December of 2016
while season 2 premiered in late April
of 2018 and ended in late June since
season 2 began filming in the summer of
2017
that left around 10 months between the
start of production and the show's
premier if the series remains on a
similar production schedule we can
expect to see season 3 as early as
January of 2020 but given the
increasingly vast scope of the series
from season to season it wouldn't be a
huge surprise that the wait turns out to
be even longer
[Music]
nightmare the end of West world's second
season saw the park undergo a heap of
significant changes with a number of
important characters dying escaping or
transitioning into another reality such
seismic developments are bound to ripple
out through the show's third season and
if the trailer is any indication the new
episodes will look and feel very
different from what's come before we
have to be smart
where they'll find us
however not everything will seem strange
and new and westward returns for its
third season as several main cast
members have already had their returns
confirmed these include the damsel
turned revolutionary Dolores Abernathy
host creator and then wit Singh Arnold
replicas Bernard Lowe the mysterious man
in black head of security Ashley Stubbs
the host that looks like Charlotte Hale
and somewhat surprisingly former madam
Maeve Miller who sacrificed herself at
the end of season two in order to allow
her daughter a chance to escape the park
and enter the digital utopia of the
sublime of course everyone knows that
death is merely temporary for the host
of West world and Newton confirmed that
she'll be back for season three in a
2018 interview with Vanity Fair you
think I'm scared of death
I've done a million times while a number
of familiar faces are returning for
season three the end of season two multi
the fin ative farewell for several
others Anthony Hopkins Park creates her
Robert Ford have been dead since the end
of season one - and although he has
continued to appear regularly in
flashbacks and visions according to
series creator Lisa joy he's now gone
for good
[Music]
puck meanwhile Jimmy Simpsons character
William will still be very much alive in
season 3 but will be portrayed
exclusively by Ed Harris a Simpson
reveal to the Television Critics
Association that he hasn't been asked to
return in previous seasons Harris played
the older William while Simpson
portrayed his younger counterparts
Shannon wood was determined true CK
Elsie was tragically murdered at the end
of season two and Jonathan Nolan has
confirmed that while there's never any
real saying goodbye in Westworld Elsie
is truly gone for now at least less
clear as the fate of James Marsden star
wars cowboy teddy introduced in the
pilots episode Teddy spend the majority
of his time on the show is to lorises
most a vote to protect her and Ally and
so he realized that she had altered his
programming Teddy killed himself near
the end of season two determined to die
rather than become a monster but the
Loris left his brain pearl in the forge
leaving his consciousness free to cross
over into the sublime nothing has yet
been said one way or another about
Marsten's return but since this is West
world you should know better than to
rule anything else beyond the addition
of Breaking Bad's are on poles of the
cast as a series regular West Wells
season 3 will see a number of new faces
join the show these include Lenawee 'the
vincent cassell kid cudi
and former NFL running back Marshawn
Lynch why would you get on that thing I
don't know about that so where I'm from
like we don't we don't wear it off
judging by the trailer it seems as
though weight and Lynch will be playing
Paul's accomplices in some sort of bank
heist
while Cuddy's character who also seems
to have some sort of tie to Paul's
character will be spending at least some
of his time in prison
at the end of season two most of the
hosts either traveled into the sublime
or were destroyed and were claimed by
Dallos but there are still a mysterious
few whose faiths remain undecided
in the passenger dolores and the guys of
charlotte ale took five pole shaped
control units with her out of the park
each housing the consciousness of one
host just which hosts are represented by
each of those control units remain to be
seen and according to Jonathan Nolan not
even the writers had fully decided who
was in Dolores purse at the end of
season two no one explained to
Entertainment Weekly we've had some
interesting conversations but as always
with the show who remains and who
doesn't is something we're having a lot
of fun work Nolan went on to say that
when the inhabitants of those pearls are
eventually revealed the goal of the
writers is for their choices to surprise
and hopefully delight their audience
well you can probably wall out any of
the hosts who cross into the sublime
that still leaves a large number of hoes
to pick from so place your bets wisely
there is beauty and what we are
shouldn't we to try to survive while the
earliest episodes of West weld took
place almost exclusively within the park
as the series progressed so as the scope
of its setting with much of season 2
venturing into the outside world now
with each of the show's principal host
characters or living on the outside the
showrunners are eager to see what sorts
of storytelling opportunities this vast
new setting opens up joy told The Wrap
it was always a plan to explore the real
world there are three hosts out in the
world and next season will really be an
exploration of what they find that who
they become
given that Dolores and Bernard were two
of the most central characters in season
two it's probably safe to assume that
since they're both on the outside season
three will wind up spending a lot more
time outside the walls of the park add
to that the first teaser which seems to
take place exclusively in the real world
and it would be reasonable to wonder
what are the west-world centric days of
West world might be over although a few
main characters have managed to escape
Ford's world there are still others left
on the inside with several theme parks
remaining unexplored in addition to West
world season to introduce viewers to
Shogun world and the rush but the show's
official Della's destinations website
ceases three additional parks the site
lists no details about them but Nolan
enjoy a previously hinted that the show
may eventually visit the Roman has many
evil worlds from Michael Crichton's
original 1973 movie as for the sixth
world it could be future world which
appeared in the 1976 sequel although
Nolan and joy could just as easily
create something brand new in fact the
identity of at least one park seems have
been confirmed by the comic-con trailer
well they made was last seen shot to
death outside the entrance to the
sublime the trailer finds her looking
good as new
in a place that looks like a Nazi
occupied Europe during World War two
this may very well be a glimpse of one
of the remaining three parks
although world war ii doesn't exactly
seem like a prime vacation spot if
there's one thing that's clear about the
elite clientele of their losses theme
parks is that they're drawn to violence
settings and how much more violent can
you get than history's deadliest war in
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy revealed a
few details about Aaron Paul's
previously mysterious character hinting
that he may be a little different to the
executives scientists and socialites who
make up West world's cast of human
characters Paul will be playing a Los
Angeles construction worker named Caleb
according to Nolan he'll be the type of
person who doesn't get to go to West
world why
swells first Caesar made it clear that
only the extremely wealthy are able to
afford the hefty $40,000 per day price
tag that allows them to partake in the
violent delights of delicious themed
parks because of this the only humans at
the hopes of the parks have encountered
up until this point I've either been
employed by d-las or have all belong to
the same super elite social class but
now that the loris is outside of the
park it sounds like a horizons will
become significantly broadened and
according to nolan caleb will quote
challenge to lorises notions about the
nature of humanity although artificial
life forms are nothing new for West
world fans season 3 will nonetheless
introduce a different type of robots of
the hosts who have appeared so far shown
hanging out with our own poles
construction worker Caleb in HBO's
initial teaser for season 3 George is a
standard construction robots
Della's model G 267 built to serve as a
helpful coworker for Caleb George
doesn't speak and likely won't have much
in common with his mechanical
counterparts from inside the park in his
Entertainment Weekly interview Nolan
said part of what our hosts finders are
they're caught in between their fashion
to look like human beings and act like
them but they have a lot more in common
with the mechanical pieces in our world
robots like George in the other
real-world worker BOTS limps in the fall
season 3 trailer will play an important
role in the upcoming season contrasting
the human-like traits of the host with
their mechanical origins while the hosts
have been designed to act as emotional
mirrors to human guests in the loser's
parks these more utilitarian robots have
been designed with specific uses in mind
yes science check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]